Why is Poop Brown?
Poop is brown due to bile from your gall bladder
being metabolized by the bacteria in your
intestines.
This results in a byproduct called stercobilin,
which, in turn, makes poop look brown-ish.
Without this stercobilin, your poop would
typically look grey-ish/white.
Because of this, a sure sign you are having
problems with bile production, such as a blocked
bile duct by a gall stone or something more
serious like pancreatic cancer, is if you
notice your poop is this white/grey-ish color.
In the end *pun intended*, brown poop is a
pretty good sign you are a relatively healthy
individual.
Some other common poop colors that generally
aren’t a good sign of health are as follows:
If you notice your poop is red, this could
be a sign of internal bleeding or could just
mean you’ve recently eaten beets.
If the cause is bleeding and the bleeding
is from your stomach or throat, however, your
poop won’t be red, but rather black and
will smell worse than that time you decided
you should eat a box of Twinkies and a box
of Cheesy Handi-Snacks all in one sitting.
Yellow poop means there is a lot of fat in
your feces.
This is not a good sign.
Consider turning this into a positive by making
poop candles with your fatty deposits.
Yellow poop also has a very strong odor, which
will give your poo-candles that little something
extra.
Green poop is an indicator of some sort of
bacterial infection or that you
are
a vegetarian and eat way too much leafy foods